foreign
[Music]
like that
don't get a Twist of Young Blood
I still got it it wasn't the plan
initially though I put this up for
Carlton
and then he went and fell in love with
lacrosse and race cars
ah
it's even a little off your game well
let's wait on you nothing you don't
already know
humor me
you ever been arrested
no
no I can't say that I have
it's like
a movie playing in my head
you get thrown to the ground
handcuffed
picked up like garbage
thrown in the back of a cruiser and the
whole time I know
any movement any sudden move I like to
be gone like this
every time I touch a ballet
plays over and over again
sorry I had to go through that
like I didn't fight back I didn't resist
and they still rough me up I know
I know it's tragic it's proof how broken
the system is you see that's the thing
to me system isn't broken to me the
system is doing exactly what it was
designed to do I hear that
but from where I stand
things have gotten better
incrementally for you look at where you
at
look how you live
what are the rest of us supposed to do I
don't know what everyone else is
supposed to do
but I know that neither of us should
give up
you ever quit on the court
no
don't start now
easiest way to get back in the game
before we can get out of our own heads
[Music]
see just like that
all right getting that Rhythm right
there you go there you go beautiful well
come on now
oh hey
come on now what
all right nephew
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]